(box opening)
(cards falling)
(cards sliding)
(pieces jingling)
- What's your strangest pregnancy craving?
- Peanut butter and Oreos.
- Peanut butter and bacon sandwiches.
I don't know why
- It sounds crazy, but corn starch
(record scratching)
(crickets chirping)
- [Group] I'm pregnant.
- [Narrator] Five are posers.
One is the real deal.
In a room full of liars, can
these teams find the real deal?
(gentle guitar music)
- So like about how many
weeks until you due date?
- Two weeks from tomorrow. (chuckles)
- Say a week and a half.
- Three weeks.
- It's 15 weeks.
- Two weeks left.
- I have two weeks left.
- Two weeks left. Okay.
What's your strangest pregnancy craving?
- It's not that strange,
but I never really had a sweet
tooth until I got pregnant.
- Peanut butter and Oreos.
- Just sounds good.
(group laughs)
- It sounds crazy, but corn starch.
- Like by itself, just like spoonfuls?
- Yes.
- Mine is peanut butter
and bacon sandwiches.
I don't know why.
- I think it's all the
things that I can't eat.
So like I want sushi and sahimi.
I want like, just like
a cold meat sandwich.
- I want everything spicy.
Anything hot.
- No, that checks out.
Walk us through like, your
day-to-day workout routine,
if there is a workout routine.
- Well, I don't go to the gym.
I feel like there's things
that you can do to keep active
so you're not so stagnant.
And right now, since I'm so far along,
it's just like how many
times an hour can I get up.
- Right.
- And walk to the other
side of my apartment.
- I usually walk, but I do work out.
I used to lift heavy, but now
I have to use lighter weights.
- My workout is chasing my two other kids.
(overplay of children laughing)
And sitting down when I can. (laughs)
- That's a good answer.
- I like to do yoga.
I kind of just keep it minimal.
I used to do yoga before I was pregnant.
It's a little harder now,
but I try to keep as active as possible.
- So I try to walk about
20 minutes every day
and then also just doing a
lot of squats is really good.
- It's also good for your booty.
(upbeat rock music)
I've heard.
- Yeah.
(group laughs)
- Like she said, I just
chase after my two year old.
- I think we're ready
to make an elimination.
(upbeat intense music)
- [Narrator] Each team will try to find
the real deal by
eliminating the imposters.
If both teams eliminate the same person,
they will be removed from the game.
(mark scratching)
- She was talking about how her workout
was walking across the room and back.
- She was just playing
up to it a little bit.
- How often do you guys pee?
- All the time.
And as the pregnancy gets further along,
just more consistently throughout the day.
It's really annoying actually, so.
- I would say I wake up
like, four or five times
in the middle of the night.
- It's the same amount.
About four or five times during the night.
I'm still breastfeeding too,
so I'm waking up to feed.
- It's every hour for me.
I actually have to pee really soon.
(toilet flushing)
- I go probably every
two hours during the day
and then at night, I get up
around five to six times.
- My bladder is always getting danced on.
- Yeah.
- Like, I would use a restroom
and then like sometimes
would have to go back.
Like, I thought I emptied it.
Yeah, no. (laughs)
- I was kind of looking
out for who was trying
to like, explain too much.
- Do you have any baby names planned?
- And is it a boy or a girl?
- If you know already, yeah.
- I don't wanna know.
- Okay.
- I want it to be a surprise,
but if it's a girl, she'll be Deana.
A couple weeks after I found
out that I was pregnant,
my grandmother named Deana passed away
and we were very close,
so that's the only one
and I feel that she's a girl.
That would be really special to me.
- I don't know yet.
I'm undecided because yeah.
Probably Trent Jr.
- So my two other kids, they have Z names,
so the last one I want to be Zion.
- It's my first girl so
I wanna name her Emery.
I want my kids names to be all colors.
- She's a girl and I wanted a name
that like, represented peace
so her name's gonna be Shiloh.
- So this time I chose
to wait until birth.
So if it's a girl, Aailyah,
and if it's a boy, Robert Jr.
(sad trumpet playing)
I don't want that, so I hope it's a girl.
- Okay, I think we're ready
to make an elimination.
(upbeat intense music)
- [Narrator] As a reminder,
if both teams eliminate
the same person, that person
will be removed from the game.
(marker scratching)
- I'd love to hear from number two.
I'm scared to ask this
because my mom told me
never ask a question like this.
- Oh, my God.
- How big is your baby?
- Last time I went to the doctor,
they said it was eight and a half pounds.
- And then same question number six.
- Seven pounds.
- Baby number four?
- I think the last time they said
it was four and a half pounds.
- What's the craziest
thing that happens to you
during pregnancy that might not be known?
If number three could answer that question
and then number five.
- You have a lot of hip
issues, a lot of hip problems.
Bladder issues, of course,
and then you have hormonal issues.
And then the last thing
I would say is probably
just the physical wear and
tear that you go through.
- I think a lot of people will talk about
like, the good things.
Like oh, you're glowing
when you're pregnant.
- Right.
- People don't talk about
like, the difficult things
that come with pregnancy.
Like, you don't have your body.
- Could we hear from number three?
What kind of vitamins
have you had to take?
- So I take, I can't think
of it off the top of my head.
Olly. The brand, Olly.
It's a prenatal vitamin.
It's like a gummy.
That's like the highlight of
my day because I love gummies.
- Number four, if you could
answer the same question.
- I am very like, vitamin deficient
so I just take like, what I normally take.
But I just started taking,
I don't know what it's called exactly,
but they're like mushroom pills.
I have a health condition
and it could affect my baby
so I have to like, be on
top of my game all the time.
- And then number two,
same question to you.
- I just take prenatal vitamins
and I try to eat healthy.
- Ready?
- I think we're ready.
- Yeah. (upbeat intense music)
(slow Arabian music)
Body language was a big
aspect for number two.
Just the way that she kept
her hands to her sides
and she was just a
little more like, rigid.
Just not like very like,
conscious of like, her belly.
- Number four.
Will you tell me what's the relationship
with the baby's father?
- Yeah, it's my long
term, well, now fiance.
- And were you guys trying to have a baby?
- No, it was a surprise, honestly
and I was on birth control.
Scary.
- Yeah.
- Number one, what was your
reaction when you found out?
- I was terrified.
The baby's father and I
are really good friends,
so we're not even in a relationship,
but he's been super, super supportive
and someone I care about very much.
So we're doing the whole
co-parenting thing.
- For number five, did
you have a baby shower?
And if not, are you going to?
- We had our baby shower already.
- Yeah, okay. What was
the best gift you got?
- Well, we had our dresser,
like the baby changing dresser, on there,
which was like, a really pricey gift
so I feel really thankful my
stepbrother got that for us.
- Number one, what is a diaper genie?
- Diaper genie is this like, contraption
that makes it faster to change baby
and to get rid of the diaper.
- Can number two answer
that question, as well?
- Pretty much you put your
dirty diapers in the trash can
and yeah, it doesn't
really smell up the room.
- Dude, I'm honestly ready
to eliminate someone.
- Okay, I think we're ready to eliminate.
(upbeat intense music)
(slow music)
(marker scratching)
- [Crew Member] Number two.
Unfortunately, our teams do not believe
that you are the real deal,
so we will have you
removed from the lineup.
Thank you so much.
- Sorry.
(group chuckling)
- Most of the women have
their hands on their bellies
and like, under their bellies
and she was talking like
this with her hands out
and I think that's like,
what threw her off.
- I think we have a
question for number four.
What kind of test did you have to take
at like, the doctor's office
before, you know, during
your pregnancy so far?
- I've just had like, checkups on.
Do you know what a pap smear is?
I've just had like that
every like, three months.
But no, not anything
that I needed as of now.
- Same question to number six.
- I forgot what it's called,
but you drink a nasty sugary drink
and yeah, you can't eat before.
You can't eat like, an hour
after so like, you're starving
and then like, you're drinking
like straight up sugar.
- And then for number five, same question.
- So I had the same one.
That's the check if we
have gestational diabetes.
(soft upbeat music)
- Okay, I think we're ready to lock in.
(upbeat intense music)
(funky guitar music)
- Number five, I would love
to see your like, best strut.
(group laughing)
- Oh, that's a nice look.
- Oh, thanks. (laughs)
(camera clicking)
(upbeat techno music)
- And number one, could you also possibly
like, make it up your runway?
(upbeat techno music)
(camera flashing)
- (laughs) Beautiful.
- I think we're ready.
- Yeah, I think we're also ready.
- Yeah.
(upbeat intense music)
- We think the real deal is number five.
She just really knew what
she was talking about
and everything just kind of like aligned
with like, our perception
of a pregnant woman.
- We think the real deal is number five
because, well, I think the
walk sold it for us for sure.
- [Narrator] In the event of a tie,
the team that locked in
the real deal first wins.
- [Crew Member] It is now
time to reveal your answers.
You have both chosen
pregnant woman number five.
If the lights on the lineup turn green,
that means that you have
chosen the real deal.
If the lights turn red, that
means that you have chosen
an imposter and you both lose.
Here we go.
Your answer will be revealed to you
in three, two, one.
(dramatic whooshing)
(contestants cheering)
- We did it.
- Oh, my God, my heart.
Thank you for being pregnant.
- You're welcome. I'm very impressed.
You asked that baby genie. I
don't even know what that is.
- Really?
- So I'm glad that you that you
didn't ask me that question.
- My mom just told me
to ask that. (laughs)
- Because team boys was able
to lock in the real deal first,
they will actually win the prize today.
(gentle music)
- The experience was really fun.
Like I shared, I only
have about two weeks left
so I think leading up to
this, I just kept thinking,
oh, my gosh, she needs to stay in my belly
until this shoot is over.
- She was just like, more energetic
than the rest of the moms.
I feel like what really helped us lock in
was her knowing about
the gestational diabetes.
- That's actually what
we were looking for.
- We had it between like,
number one and number five.
- Yeah.
- But it was very clear that
she was a really good actress.
- This is my first pregnancy.
I'm really, really excited.
It's like, it's such a privilege
and an honor to be able to be a mom.
Like, do I have everything in me
to be able to protect this child
and to like, help her
grow into this world?
Me and my husband Paulo, we'll
do our best to create a space
where she feels loved and seen and heard.
We're grateful for the
community that we have
and I hope that other pregnant women feel
that it's okay to be scared
and also feel okay to
depend on other people.